in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Geoff
and Angela are with us hey guys how are
you hey excellent how are you welcome
welcome where're you from
thank you Thunder Bay Ontario Canada
Ontario that's Halton Elizabeth in the
hall bit of a halt in Nashville so how
much debt have you paid off you're here
to do your debt-free scream lately fifty
eight thousand seven hundred four
dollars and ten cents I love it how long
did that take twenty five months
way to go and a range of income during
that time he started off at 115 and
ended up at 130 excellent very cool very
cool what kind of debt was this owe to
of it was student loans so what was left
after paying on student loans for ten
years we had four credit cards two lines
of credit and a car loan ah you were
normal you were in so normal and normal
sucks so you decide not to do it anymore
absolutely so tell me what happened 25
months ago that caused us to change so
we just came back from a trip to Walt
Disney World which was sponsored by
MasterCard and I came home and kind of
freaked out at how I was going to make
yet one more minimum payment we had a
good income and had absolutely nothing
to show for it so it was the season of
Lent I had given up watching TV but did
not give up Google so I added up all the
bills went on to Google googled how to
get out of debt fast and your name and
the baby steps came up and I just just
went right in there it is it works it's
simple I can do this let's do it okay
and so you sat down with Jeff and you
said uh things are getting ready change
what happens when I was a well being the
man of house full of girls he was
hanging out in the garage and he came in
he came in I said okay this is what
we're gonna do and he kind of looked at
me like I've heard this before of it
okay what are you thinking Jeff with
this conversation again just another
okay this is another get out of debt
program that a couple of them hadn't
worked before we tried but had failed
and this one come along and you just it
was simple the steps are out there and
just follow this one and go to the next
one and all of a sudden death start
getting paid off
and you start gaining traction and it
starts to get exciting
oh sorry driving I'm in a car for five
hours on the way to Minneapolis for a
weekend listening to your podcast also
helped to convince some that this is
probably the way we should go your
podcast is so infectious that I dare
anybody to listen to one or two of your
shows and not be absolutely hooked and
absolutely say hey I can do this because
you talk to people who have $20,000
making up to 200 and 300 thousand
dollars they've all got debt but they
can all get out of debt and that's what
makes the program so great okay so you
started and I would have to Jeff a bit a
bit cynical and you started going yeah
right kind of an eye roll and that kind
of thing but at what point did you
really start thinking this one might be
different well it got different I think
when I wanted to go and do something and
I said alright I need some money to go
and do this or that or buy this or that
and and said that's not in the budget
and I looked at her I said what do you
mean budget like we'll just put it on
credit and she says no we don't do that
anymore and so I learned that if I
wanted to do something we had the money
to do it but I had to think about what I
was doing before I did it
mmm and that's what makes this program
work so well is that you can do stuff
with your money as long as you write
down and go here this is what I'm doing
with the money this month yeah and
because it's not restrictive to the
point where you can't do anything it's
just here it is if you want it to be but
it's up to you
exactly exactly communication - we
learned how to communicate over money
we'd never talked about money before it
was just there and we'd spent it and
he'd spend it and I resent him so I'd go
spend money and then he'd resent me and
he'd go spend money was just a vicious
cycle of not communicating about the
money so she says she says no it's not
in the budget and you said so teach me
about this budget thing I got to figure
out how to get it in the budget
exactly exactly eating and fishing had
to find its way into the budget okay
there's nothing wrong with that nothing
wrong with it at all I love it
very cool now your daughter's I guess
are with you what are their ages in
names this is Brooklyn and she will be
nine next month and this is Emma and she
just turned 11 all right very cool so
have they kind of participated or they
just had to endure this process there
was a lot of enduring but also a lot of
learning to say it's not in the budget
and I think they're a little tired of
hearing that so they're happy happy to
hear that some things are making it back
into the budget now well now there's
room in the budget fifty nine thousand
dollars later yeah and you did that in
25 months that's impressive you all so
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is when they hear
you paid off fifty nine thousand dollars
I think the first thing of course is
getting on the budget but for us we've
done budgets before but they've never
worked because we never checked in with
the budget we just sort of wrote it down
and then sort of ignored it so going
back in checking in with the budget and
then always keeping that in mind if
anything came up having to go back in
and sort of reef and dangle some numbers
and make it work so that we were always
those mid mid mid month course
adjustment some pleasant ones absolutely
things came up for sure
but yeah just making sure your numbers
are always on track and being conscious
and intentional mm-hmm okay and when you
start doing all that you start telling
your money what to do absolutely then
you make different choices what Jeff was
saying a minute ago and you're you know
you of course the big choice here is
your I mean you did what two to three
thousand dollars a month now it's death
on average yeah that's pretty strong it
was it was some ones were harder than
others but yeah absolutely yeah it's an
average over a two year period of time
so you've been on beans and rice I mean
you had to really watch what you were
doing we have we have because we didn't
where were some things we didn't
necessarily want to sacrifice so both
the girls are involved in figure skating
and that is not a cheap sport but we
wanted to make sure that they were still
able to do that so definitely making it
work meant paying very close attention
yeah okay very cool very cool so the
budgets one of the keys any other keys
the budget I'd the budget and
communicating communicating me force you
guys to communicate better than you ever
had absolutely forces you to communicate
and yeah the budget it tells you what
you can and can't do with the money
that's coming in yeah
and if everybody was just on a budget
that they they spoke
about at the beginning of the month
before all the money was spent mm-hmm
it would bring so many more couples
together and it would let them know here
this is what we can do this month and if
we want to do other things we have to
make sacrifices mm-hmm and that's yeah
that's the key yeah I think this why
this every dollar budget online but just
working so well with the apps on the
phones because every bike and just check
and you can do those mid-course
adjustments and you got to wait an extra
way to communicate
absolutely absolutely very cool very
cool what was the hardest part of this
for you all say no yeah the trips to
Florida so of course being where we are
the winters can be a little bit cold and
excruciating his parents go down to
Florida every year for three months and
we'd always join them for a week spend
March break down there visiting the
grandparents and for the last couple
months or for the last couple years it
meant saying no and that was tough
giving up those yearly trips to Florida
was definitely actually caught it makes
the cold even colder it makes it so cold
especially when they're posting pictures
of palm trees and sands oh my god yeah
me here
thank you Facebook's rubbing nose in it
oh it's a pile of snow in front of your
house yeah Wow all right very cool all
right
Jeff and Angela Brooklyn and Alma from
Ontario Canada $59,000 paid off in 25
months making 115 to 130 pounds
great job you guys great job I love it I
love it I love it that is how it's done
and I definitely got to come south where
it's warmer for this debt free scream so
there you go
good stuff hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income